Well actually surveys I have seen
indicate about 40% of scientists believe
in a god to whom one may pray an
expectation of an answer that's not a
god,
uh,
who went off after con creating the
universe and did something else.
That's a god who's interested in human
beings.
40%,
uh,
would adhere to that statement.
The numbers are smaller when you ask
members of the National Academy of
Sciences and just various reasons people
have proposed why so called elite
scientists have an even lower proportion
of believers.
Uh,
but it's not as devastatingly absent
from the scientific community as people
might assume based on the fact that the
pronouncements they hear coming from
scientists are usually more in the
skeptical or even atheistic perspective.
I think whether or not a scientists are
believers,
uh,
should not have a whole lot to do with
how they conduct science.
The fact that I am a believer as far as
I'm aware of has had very little
influence on my scientific work.
And I think that's important to keep
that distinction.
If I'm asking a scientific question,
it's the tools of science I should be
using.
And not assuming that something
supernatural happened in the test tube
at that moment.
And that would explain my data point a.
So I do think people of faith and people
who don't have faith are capable of
thoughtful,
ethical decision making.
So any notion that we are becoming less
ethical as scientists because of a
diminution and religious faith,
I think has to be actually countered by
a arguments to say that as sense of
ethical behavior is not a distributed,
uh,
to just to people who are in fact
interest in spiritual matters.
Um,
so I'm not sure,
I think it would diminish the
hostilities which are bad for our
culture if more scientists were in fact
willing to stand up and say that faith
and science need not to be in conflict.
Because right now that's a minority view
that doesn't get heard very much.
And it's apparent to some people that
were having more of a cultural war,
a war that seems to imply that some
worldview needs to win and some
worldview needs to lose.
I would not want to look forward to a
culture where science lost and religious
faith became the dominating force.
For Truth.
I would not want to live in a culture
where faith lost and science with all of
its reductionism and it's materialism
became the sole source of truth.
I think we need both kinds of truth.
We need both kinds of world views.
To the extent that scientists can help
with that realization of the duel,
uh,
ways of finding answers to the
appropriate kind of questions that each
worldview can ask,
then I think that would be a good thing.
Certainly sociobiologists,
uh,
have put forward arguments that religion
could have an evolutionary basis that we
humans are designed in a certain way to
look for agency behind actions that we
don't understand and that may then
relate to a why various cultures.
Over time I have identified something
mysterious and supernatural outside of
their own experience to try to explain
things that didn't otherwise have an
explanation.
I think it's too simple a to basically
say,
well that does it.
Either.
God is true.
Our God is not true either.
God is real.
Our God is not real.
It's not a matter of whether you can
explain it away by a hypothesis.
The question is what's the real answer?
And I think far too few people have kind
of looked at the question from that
perspective.
What's the evidence for the idea that
God exists or doesn't exist?
I think anyone who's looked at that
would conclude that the strong atheist
position of saying,
I know there is no god,
is not an easy one to sustain.
Uh,
it,
it basically implies a certain degree of
Hubris and arrogance to say that I know
so much that I could exclude any
possibility of there being a god.
On the other hand,
the evidence will never draw people to
the conclusion of saying,
I know confidently there is a god.
Maybe God didn't intend it to be that
easy.